[Music]
hello and welcome to this video yeah
this video deals with rather white
complex of opening names but the
starting moves are quite similar yeah we
are dealing with the pills defense the
modern defense and the Philidor in this
video which means the defenses that can
start with d6 g6 or combination of those
moves in fact we can basically
differentiate between two complexes here
one is the Philidor where black starts
with d6
early on and later intends to play e5
and Bishop to e7 or the Piltz modern
where there is usually a king site
fianchetto
played by black so i want to start with
the philidor's defense and then switch
over to the % modern so we go in for and
d6 is a starting move to initiate the
philidor's to clarify things we already
have looked at the Philidor defense in
an earlier video which started like this
this is the move order how freedom yep
envisioned his opening to be played yeah
hundreds of years ago in fact nowadays
black usually uses this move order to
get to positions associated with the
philidor's we go deform and black goes
Knight to f6
first of all attacking our pawn black or
zone might go a five in this position
rare but possible
in fact he offers the potential Queen
trade here after this which is not
something I do recommend white might be
slightly better
this position but it's so feels a little
bit a little bit toothless to trade that
early on Knight f3 transposing to a
regular philidor's is probably the best
and most ambitious option here Knight f6
is mainly played with play Knight c3
cover the pawn and now II five leads to
the modern order of the philidor's in
the finis door chapter with 1.e4 e5
Knight f3 d6 I have explained why this
is nowadays the common way to reach that
at the setup that black wants to go for
it's not reachable by e4 e5 Knight f3 d6
there are move order issues okay II five
buy black again we would have this
option now to take on e5 and go into an
ending with this this is not all that
promising for white one issue is that
after Bishop c4 King 8 in fact seems to
be not much at all for the white player
but surprisingly I think it looks like
why should have a slight bullet there is
really not that much going on it is a
more ambitious choice to play Knight e3
this is the absolute main line there
nowadays not the caption note that black
in this position also has alternatives
and we should look at them quickly
Knight bt7
is a way to play in order to prepare
prevent and prepare high five without
allowing the D takes d5 Queen's rate
Knight pd7 here I recommend to simply
play Knight f3 and after if I've to
transpose into a position then we will
look at in just a minute we will play
Bishop c4 here by the way
I have to mention that in this
particular position there are
alternatives here for white that are in
fact far more aggressive and to try to
punish in some way blacks move order
Liberty with 9b d7 the move mostly am
deemed as critical here is actually g4 a
bit of an extreme looking move from this
flank push but there is a real logic
behind it with the Knights positioned as
they are g5 is a serious very serious
threat now because the knight on f6 is
never natural retreating square the
reason why I'm not covering this year is
that is in fact rather complicated if
Blanco was age 665 if he knows what he's
doing this is probably a little bit
better for white but rather complicated
and I felt this is an additional
workload that is unnecessary for line
that would probably never pop up if you
ever however expect your opening to your
opponent to play like that you can
definitely think about preparing g4 in
some detail but I don't think it's worth
learning just to be ready for this odd
moment that this is going to be played
against you um black also in this
position
besides g6 which is the Phills offense
has to move c6 I want to look at this
later because some lines there are more
looking like a pills and philidor's it's
all a little bit of a transpositional
may see and some in some cases there was
d 6g six lines they they sometimes don't
have such a concrete move orders so
let's go look at the philidor's with E 5
again I recommend 93m now the move that
black mostly plays is Knight B to d7
that was his intention when he opted for
this move order in the field
or to reach the Philidor black once the
planar bd7 end for the time being simply
fortified the pawn on d5 who would the
center there are alternatives but they
are all leading to positions and lines
that we have looked at before for
example black kickers take and after
Knight takes we reach an open Philidor
position that we've looked at via the
traditional e4 e5 Knight f3 d6 d4 move
order Bishop d7 g3 was the main line
there black might also play knight c6
after which I recommend Bishop to b5
this is transposing to basically a squad
for Knights declined we're after d4
black plate d6 so this is covered
already elsewhere 9b d7 is by far the
most common move and it is somewhat like
usually had in mind when he went for
this opening in the first place so what
am I going to play Bishop to c4 this is
I think the most promising move and also
the main line for ages and very reliable
it positions the bishop on the most
active diagonal very natural play here
blacks main move is Bishop to e7 and
probably also the best move we can look
at alternatives however if black now
takes it is in fact a little bit yeah
inconsistent to do that now because if
you want to take on the form in the
first place it doesn't make that much
sense to commit to Knight bg7
and so taking on four is more logical
that being said we have to still know
what to do here in fact I think there
are two decent moves the move Queen
takes d4
leads to a position that we have
actually covered while the a45 neither 3
d6 move water but Knight takes d4 isn't
bad
either after this move black might have
night my to play Knight b6 after which
we will drop back to e 2 this is a
position after further B should be seven
castles then we're going to look at in
just a moment
note that here you would have to go back
to e2 as we should be three as leading
to trouble this Bishop doesn't have many
squares you know what's your form but as
being said critics divorce also fine
it's a completely open a choice now I
could have also just said okay tip with
the Queen isn't it transposes both
recaptures are completely fine so this
is rather rare that black takes on d4
because again usually black tries to
keep the center hold the center
for 255 and not take the move Bishop e7
it's the main line here by a mile
however I want to quickly check the move
h6 simply because this is actually
played quite frequently surprisingly
actually because Bishop e7 is completely
fine I think one reason could be that
black players when they reach this
position and they actually don't ya know
stuff but try to yeah calculate it over
the board they might be afraid that but
should be seven that could be lights
with bishop takes on ninety five and all
this is stopped by h6 so pretty a slow
move and black however could have a
different idea with age six and this
idea could be I hope you enjoyed this
preview of the keep it simple efore
repertoire you can get the full course
on chasuble comm which features the move
trainer that makes it easy and simple to
learn all the nice and remember them and
all the lights are chosen with one thing
in mind keep it simple for you and make
it difficult for your opponent
[Music]
you